listen I I really want to start with
congrats on the movie um for you never
know when you're making something what
the reaction's going to be because I've
seen films that are amazing get a
negative reaction and you know things
that I thought were terrible people love
but so I'm curious uh you guys made a
great movie and people think it's great
so what has it been like for you guys uh
with the audience reaction to the film I
mean I suppose our first our first sense
of an audience reaction was when we
premiered at Sundance and it
was it was on some ofel
um it was an experience because it was
1,200 seat theater and we had never seen
the audience with a um the movie with an
audience before so to to to be sitting
in that audience and to see the movie on
the big screen for the first time with
that many people you really get a sense
of whether the audience like the movie
or not yeah I mean there's no way of
actually escaping that and as a
filmmaker when you put so much care and
attention uh and love and hard work into
a
movie you know you you just hope that
people are going to respond to the movie
and love it as much as you do and I
think broadly that's what I felt when I
sat there in Sundance that we that
people were engaging with it in the
right way yeah that was its test
screening that was really the test
screening and the like gasp of the
majority of those audience members at
the moment you want them to gasp was so
satisfying in the laughter just yeah
things Landing it was such a thrill yeah
I mean if anything I would just I'm so
I'm so happy that we get to show this
movie in cinemas because I think the
shared experience um especially at
certain key moments of the film um is
really fun and satisfying and something
that I haven't felt in a movie theater
in a long time yeah it really leaves
people wrestling too with concepts of
you know Justice and respons ability and
um people don't leave often the theater
is what we've heard and what we've seen
people stay and they sit and they're and
they're quiet and uh and I think it's
like kind of a communal catharsis that's
happening in the theater and also like
leaving people to wrestle with some
important Concepts yeah good
conversations yeah nice Christmas and
it's and I I found it very funny I mean
I found the book funny I found the
script that you guys wrote very funny
but I also find the film funny I mean
it's it's got It's a dark sense of humor
but um it's worth saying that you know
you you should find it funny as well I
mean if you you should you you you
should in a sense that if it's working
it should be funny one of the things is
that you guys made this as an indie and
I and I think that that allowed you guys
to be able to do what you did with this
film because I I do think if a studio
had made this um you would not have been
maybe as able to take a sharp left turn
uh the way that the film does without
maybe more setup and I I think we were
really lucky that the three of us could
uh originate and develop this um
project and everyone who signed on to
work on it wanted to make this movie not
some other version of eileene um so we
were all in it together and there was
never a moment where we questioned you
know whether we had taken the right
approach it was always this is this is
the story this is the character and
we're not going to sand off any of the
edges yeah one of the things I'm
fascinated by is the editing process
because it's where anything comes
together so I'm curious how did this
film possibly change in the editing room
in ways you didn't expect going in well
I was lucky that the editor was present
throughout the shoot um I always find it
helpful that Nick is the editor I've
worked with twice now once on lady Beth
and Once on This film and um he's really
such an important collaborator for me
he's somebody I trust enormously and so
having him there while we were shooting
he could also then
feedback not only because he's a fresh
pair of eyes he's not been part of the
development process or the adaptation
process he's just really seeing what's
coming to him each day on screen and he
can then judge it sort of impartially if
you like but also because every day then
he can we can watch the stuff together
we can make sure that it is coming
together he can cut it together and if
there's stuff that's missing then we can
go and get the extra we can pick things
up as as we go through
um I think that our process is fairly
straightforward you know we we we just
follow the movie as it unfolds we we
listen to the film that's in front of us
so we've had a process of developing the
idea the script has been written and the
movie has been short and now the movie
is the thing that's in front of us and
we have to listen to what that thing
needs so it's a very he's very
responsive in that sense to the
requirements um
uh you know sometimes we have to sort of
do things just to sort of refresh our
own eyes and shake it up a bit change a
few scenes around move things about so
that we can see it see it aesh but
um it's a for me it's it's important
it's very very important and I I feel
privileged because not many people get
to sit through a four five month edit of
a movie um but I think it teaches you so
much about film making I mean I you know
I think that actors don't see it through
the the the crew don't sit through um
the edit but I wonder whether if they
sat through something like that they
would understand a little bit about how
what I'm thinking about having been
through one you know I'm thinking about
what I'm going to be doing for the next
four months while everyone goes on to
their next job and I'm sitting there
thinking wish I had this moment or I
wish we had got that in a different way
or something it's uh it's one of the
best and most exciting uh aspects of
film making for me Essa it's not often
that the person who wrote the book gets
to work on the screenplay so talk a
little bit about what it was like sort
of editing your own material and trying
to bring it into you know 120 page
script or however long it was well it
was
exciting and
um really interesting to approach the
material that I had written by myself
with my partner um my co-writer Luke
Goble um who who you know helped me see
the story um in a new way for
Cinema the character got more
multi-dimensional in that uh I was
seeing her from the outside whereas
before I was just on her inside sort of
narrating through her I'm C for for both
of you the the film I love the way the
film ends uh but I believe the book ends
a different way and uh I'm curious how
you guys decided without spoilers where
you wanted the film to end and did you
ever think about something else I mean
anytime that you adapt a firstperson
narrative I think there's the question
of like is this a voiceover and I think
we were all really um impassion emphatic
that it couldn't be a voice over for
several reasons but we didn't want to
end in we didn't want to begin with
Eileen being safe um there needed to be
a danger and a concern for her as a
character um that not having a voice
over that tells us how she ends up and
that you know she's succeeded in making
it to old age um was essential and also
we wanted all that pressure of the
period and the location and the nature
of of Eileen that Thomasson so perfectly
captures that oppression and repression
to be bottled up until Rebecca arrives
on scene and this glamorous enigmatic
presence offers a sounding board for
Eileen to reconsider who she could
possibly be in this world well me I'm
curious when you looked at this schedule
for what you needed to shoot what was
the day you had circled as to I'm not
sure how we're going to do this in the
time frame we have uh the
basement because it was
uh it shot in a day uh and that was uh
very very uh tight uh to shoot I mean
what must be 10 minutes I think of it
must be like 10 12 pages in a day yeah I
it's sort
of it's It's you can you can it's easy
to think oh well it's one scene we can
just shoot it in a day it's like
self-contained but there was so many
moving parts so many elements of that
scene which we could break down and you
could shoot over several days I
mean um yeah that was a tough tough day
not just because we were up against the
clock but because of what the actors had
to go through to deliver those
performances it was
um yes and it was the penal there the
shoot as well so everyone was quite
tired by that
point uh I can't believe you shot that
in a day yeah uh but it also helps when
you have great actors doing the scene
that's true no it's it's really a
testament to them yeah for all three of
you I always of course like to ask about
what you're working on now so let me ask
what are you guys excited for for next
week next week next year is there
anything that you're working on well and
next week we were all working together
in fact we liked each other so much
through this process that we decided to
try and make another one together oh is
that true yeah yeah uh are you are you
adapting another book no it's an
original idea it's an original
screenplay based on the sort of facts of
a woman's life from the middle of the
last century yeah a woman who was
accused of Witchcraft she was a psychic
medium and uh inadvertently was
contacted by a dead sailor and revealed
the whereabouts of a sunk Naval
Battleship which got into a lot of
trouble and so she was then accused of
Witchcraft in the Old Bailey tried and
convicted in fact using a Witchcraft Act
of
1735 in England in England do
happens uh well first of all that sounds
cool and second of all I have to wrap
I'm just gonna say that congrats on this
I look forward to seeing whatever you
guys are doing next and thank you for
giving me your time thank you very much
thank
you